mickey mouse is that again just a few
weeks ago disney owned national
geographic gave us the documentary
fouchy a puff piece meant to resurrect
the career of a guy who's been wrong
pretty much about everything
now disney owned hulu has another super
villain they're trying to fit into the
glass slipper christopher steele author
of the dirty and very discredited
dossier the former spy sat down with
george stephanopoulos for a new
documentary series and is being
portrayed as a hero for taking on trump
and putin
christopher steele is an enigma is he
hero is he traitor christopher steele is
a guy who picked a fight with two
presidents donald trump and vladimir
putin and he's lived to tell the tale
when you bring the information to the
fbi in 2016 reacting as a patriot or a
paid private intelligence officer i mean
this is the stuff of movies i think a
lot of this is the stuff of movies
i wonder whose reputation they're going
to try to repair next andrew cuomo bill
cosby oj
let's ask congressman devin nunes of
california so yeah this is disney owned
they hate trump this is stephanopoulos
he's a clinton flack at abc
and they're just trying to make this guy
look better who's in all reality a total
scoundrel
well jesse i would say this that
this is even far beyond where i'd expect
them to go because anybody if you do a
little bit of research so i don't know
what stepanopolis did
but in our investigation that we did we
actually found that still probably
didn't even write these dossiers number
one because there was a set of
pre-dossiers that essentially had some
of the same stories now did still
develop the infamous peepee tape that
everybody talks about that's actually in
that promo which is outlandish
you know we don't know if they're going
to ask the right questions or not but
just remember this when we tried to
reach out to steele's lawyers when i say
we republicans on the intelligence
committee when we were doing our
investigation still the only real
investigation we're all waiting on
durham
we reached out he didn't want to talk
the fact that he's now talking now
taking credit for something that's been
completely discredited and laughed at
that you know all the people in the
intelligence world that were looking at
this in 2016 should have known that this
was just a fraud it didn't even look
like a real intelligence report so it's
it's an embarrassment to
to disney it's an embarrassment to hulu
it's an embarrassment to the british
government and mi6 that this guy ever
work for them and look there's probably
more to come i'm sure it will be a
quite a comical and entertaining
movie i don't think they're embarrassed
at all for them this is legacy repair
this is
putting a historical record down
digitally to cover up all the dirty
deeds that these guys did so this is you
know in 50 years 75 years you know you
look back at who is christopher steele
and christopher steele is going to look
like a good guy he's going to look like
a guy that took on trump and you know
not the real
dirt bag that he actually is and when
you have the power of a hulu with disney
backing and a polished chin
stephanopoulos sitting there stroking
himself
it legitimizes someone like this who in
any sane world would be seen as one of
the dirtiest international scoundrels
in the last you know couple decades
politically and speaking of scoundrels
i'm glad i i referenced that mccabe your
good buddy over at the doj remember he
got fired for lying and leaking
not anymore he's got everything back
he's going to get his pension back the
biden doj just cut a nice deal he's he's
going to get some cuff links back that
were given to him he's going to have his
plaque back at the department of justice
and they're going to scrub and he
mentioned that he was fired from the fbi
yeah look this is uh
this is what we expect from biden's doj
i think it was a given that they were
going to do this
but that doesn't mean uh to your point
disney can do what they want to do uh
the biden doj can let people off if they
would like
durham is still out there and a lot of
the future this country really depends
on
for the department of justice and the
fbi to have any support
amongst conservatives or half of this
country
is going to really depend on who durham
indicts and i think that's what a lot of
us are waiting for it appears like he's
moving in the right direction and
hopefully he gets to finish his
investigation so we can put closure to
this but in big picture i agree with you
that's part of where we are in this
world right now you've got basically
reality and then an alternative reality
that's created by the left and it's what
we deal with every day yeah durham
better hurry up and uh a lot of pressure
on that guy i'm just i'm so happy for
mccabe to get his cufflinks back they
must be very nice cufflinks high class
problems probably when you can't have
your cufflinks i'll see you later
congressman all right hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else